the amount of rain that falls in various
cities in France varies the line plot
below shows the average monthly rainfall
in 13 different cities measurements are
rounded to the nearest 1/4 of a
centimeter how much more rain falls in
the rainiest city then the second
rainiest city so let's make sure we
understand what they're calling a line
plot right over here each of these dots
represents one of the cities whose
average monthly rainfall was measured
and so for example putting this dot here
shows that this is the only city that
had 6 centimeters of average monthly
rainfall here this shows that there were
two cities there were two cities that
haven't had an average monthly rainfall
of looks like 8 and 3/4 8 and 3/4
centimeters there are two cities that
had an average monthly rainfall of 12
and 3/4 centimeters so at any given
mount of rainfall it's essentially
showing you how many cities had that
average month that had that amount of
rainfall on average per month now what
now that we understand this diagram
let's answer the question how much more
rain falls in the rainiest city so the
rainiest city here well there's only one
city that's up here at 13 and 1/2 cent
and 1/2 centimeters of rainfall so this
right over here let me mark this off
this is 13 and 1/2 centimeters how much
more rain falls in the rainy City then
the second rainiest city well this is
the second rainy City is this city right
over here this is 13 and 1/4 centimeter
so the average the the difference
between the two is just one notch here
it's just one knotch going from 13 and
1/4 to 13 and 1/2 so whatnot right over
here we see that there's four notches
per centimeter one notch over here is
1/4 of a centimeter so just looking at
it you could say that the difference is
1/4 is 1/4 of a centimeter now if it
wasn't so clear because here we're just
looking 1 not right over here you could
take the larger of the 2 and subtract 4
that the smaller of the two so you could
take you could take 13 and 1/2 and from
that subtract 13 and 1/4 and there's
multiple ways of doing this you could
set you could subtract 13 from the 13
and then subtract the 1/4 from the 1/2
and then you would get 1/4 in other ways
you could convert these both into
improper fractions so 13 and 1/2 is the
same thing as 2 times 13 is 26 plus 1 is
27 so that's 27 over 2 and then we could
say minus C 4 times 13 is 52 plus 1 is
53 so minus 53 over 4 and then if we
want to have we in order to do the
subtraction you have to have the same
denominator and so 4 is a multiple of 2
so we just have to multiply the
numerator and denominator here by 2 so
we have 54 over 4 minus 53 over 4 which
is equal to which is equal to well 54
minus 53 is 1 over 4 1/4 of a centimeter
for this problem this would clearly be a
little bit too much that you would have
to do but this is useful to know just in
case it wasn't as obvious that these
weren't just next to each other